bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get in this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got pete
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
uh how are you pomp great to be here i'm
energized
it's a bull run there's excitement in
the air uh bitcoin's going up
it's going to be an exciting year we've
got eight months to go
uh i think you know room to run
we'll see what happens but uh i tend to
agree with you i think that you are not
wrong you are less wrong than you are
right
um all right before we get into uh
the mystery of satoshi nakamoto um walk
us through just
what have you done in bitcoin and what
are you doing today i think you've done
so much uh so just give us a little bit
of background
sure yeah pete rizzo uh editor of
bitcoin magazine editor at large the
kraken cryptocurrency exchange where i
oversee
their charitable grants to open social
developers
and those types of projects uh one of
the longest tenured
cryptocurrency journalists uh been
writing about bitcoin since 2013.
people might know me best as sort of the
editor uh former editor-in-chief of
coindesk
the industry's biggest publication and
uh yeah you know i've just some someone
who hasn't stopped
trying to understand bitcoin and i think
that has led me to
you know some places and some research
where i don't think other people would
have spent the time but
you know for me it's really just been
propelled i think recently more
more so than in the past that just this
idea that bitcoin is an invention
you know it's a it's a human achievement
it might be a human achievement on a
scale that we're you know
really even just starting to appreciate
uh today
and i think that has really driven me
late over the last couple of years to
try to understand as much as we can
you know if bitcoin really is a human
achievement then to me it's worthy of
being understood
at that level and for me that meant
going all the way to the back to the
beginning
uh and and really tracing it out because
the other thing that's amazing is
because you know
you think about there's all this
misinformation about bitcoin out there
it's such a transparent project you can
literally go back to the earliest days
you can actually see
conversations happening in real time
between people
in 2009 and 2010 talking about bitcoin
before it had a price before there were
exchanges where you could buy
bitcoin coordinating to propel this
project forward and to me i think you
know that's the stuff that i want to
bring to the surface
now especially at a time when people are
really just rediscovering a bitcoin
and you know it's much different today
uh than it was back then
so when you go all the way back to the
beginning i think that you spent a bunch
of time probably more than anybody i
know
uh trying to figure out who satoshi is
why they're important
uh and all the intricate uh details that
are
involved in that and so maybe just like
why go back and focus so much on satoshi
i would uh clarify just you know don't
think it's important who satoshi is but
you know i do think that i want to
understand satoshi as an individual who
built software right we can understand
how he ran the project we can look at
his intent and i think
for me it was just an effort to try to
make satoshi feel like less of a
you know he's always depicted as this
like black photo not found
type square of a person right but he was
a real individual that people interact
with
interacted with and for the first two
years of the project he was actually the
primary person that you interacted with
right if you had a question
about bitcoin satoshi was a guy you
emailed right he was just
another one of the people kind of
building and pushing this project
forward so for me i think
i really wanted to kind of scrape away
this this just bland image we have of
satoshi as just this kind of non-figure
and
non-person and really just add some
color or personality because i think
what's fascinating is
uh and this is just a little fact that
got me in my research is that on the
original bitcoin.org
website that satoshi launched you know
he has a whole subpage about
uh how bitcoin solves the byzantine
generals problem right that's the
computer science uh problem itself so
you know imagine being this guy
you solve uh decentralized money you
create
money out of code you know this you know
that you've done this
and then you have to wait sort of months
and and all this time as people wake up
to this idea
uh to me that was what i kind of wanted
to get out of it is really understanding
the journey that this person went
through because i think we can know that
right we have
this digital history of this individual
we might not know who he is
but again actions speak louder than
words right we can go back and see what
this individual
individual did uh we can look at you
know uh he never spent his coins he
never cashed out he was never commercial
he was never opportunistic
uh you know something that's got me
recently is you know satoshi never even
prices bitcoin
he doesn't say that bitcoin should have
a price he never tries to sell a bitcoin
uh these are things that the market was
able to do around him and i think
you know for me uh again all this kind
of contrasts in an environment where
increasingly you're seeing
cryptocurrencies being sold by
companies non-profits like organizations
uh under all sorts of claims and i think
you know
for me and my journey to understand
bitcoin i think it really uh i got to
the point where i had to spend some time
with satoshi
and say okay well what did he really do
and i think what i found is that
we just can know a lot more about that
than we have because there's just this
again this trove of data and information
that he left behind
and you know maybe he didn't give us all
the answers he doesn't explain it out
as we would want it to but uh you know
we can look at this record and
in the end i think that's better than
the sort of mythological type person
that he's become and so when you started
this journey where did you go first to
learn more about satoshi like
did you go back and read the emails did
you just start with the white paper or
where did you go yeah so there's this
fantastic resource called bitcoin talk
it's it was an early user forum for
bitcoin enthusiasts and you really can
spend a lot of time
in that archive it was actually
something that satoshi himself
launched right so uh kind of an
interesting fact is like for all this
time when satoshi
uh you know was was pushing bitcoin out
there for the first
you know nine or so months there's no
bitcoin price right it actually isn't
until he launches
forums where the users can get together
that they create an exchange in a price
right so he kind of creates this
the space for people to talk about
bitcoin and then through that there's
all this creation and my article uh last
days of satoshi out on bitcoin magazine
now sort of
gets into that right it gets into okay
these people came together
they're building exchanges it's exciting
satoshi's pushing software
and it gets into the early like trials
and tribulations as you know this
project grows and expands
and you know even then it's still worth
pennies
right like people are literally in the
beginning mining bitcoin at a loss
they're spending electricity to create
uh bitcoins which are then
worth nothing right so i think a lot of
it was trying to just get the feel of
this environment
um and to really kind of understand what
was pushing people forward at this time
right because today again this
environment is so economically
driven it's all about investment it's
all about uh
you know number go up uh and really
there was a time in bitcoin
that's like almost prehistoric now right
where this just didn't happen there was
no way to prioritize bitcoin you you
traded things for bitcoin uh you
exchanged things for bitcoin maybe it
was your time maybe it was
uh you know your intellectual output or
your art or something like that
but you know i think again i really
wanted to look into this period and
and really kind of uh bring it to the
surface in a way that maybe we hadn't
seen before
you mentioned earlier that you don't
think it's important who satoshi
actually is why is that
yeah that's a good question um well
because i think in order for bitcoin to
be bitcoin it needs to be
uh decentralized right and i think one
of the you know the
i launched this article on the 10th
anniversary of satoshi's disappearance
and i think
you know again going back to actions um
one of the things that we have from
satoshi is that
he left right i think the piece kind of
gets into that and
explores that um you know i'm not sure
after doing this research that
you know satoshi maybe could have
continued i think the uh industry
outgrew him
in some ways um but um
sorry what was your question again why
do you think it's not important
to uh know who satoshi is
right i think um because again like yeah
so satoshi is
you know um we again are the people
responsible for bitcoin right and again
with satoshi leaving i think
that's sort of the message that he
wanted to get across right it was
you know i think at some point he
recognized that users were ready
to push bitcoin forward right that they
sort of looked up to him for a while as
someone who had all the answers
and at some point bitcoin users became
self-sufficient and i think satoshi
identified that he stepped away
um and i think in that example it's not
as important to understand
who he was specifically and where he was
from because i think we also have a lot
of data about who the users are
and where they come from and and them as
a group and ultimately that's what makes
bitcoin i think special among
you know financial technologies again it
is a peer-to-peer money system
right all the users are nodes all of
them are authors of code satoshi is the
person who starts
this network right he is the one with
the idea but in a way it's it's the
users who propel the system forward even
today right it is the users who make
decisions for bitcoin
uh and in that way you know satoshi i
think over time
uh you know he had to step away for
bitcoin to become what it is
and and i actually would wonder whether
you know whether bitcoin was actually
it could have been completed with
satoshi because again it would have been
a
if you think about it what would it look
like if satoshi was still around today
and there was a single individual who
was in charge of a decentralized money
would you be saying the same things
about bitcoin being a centralized asset
would you think about it as a
centralized gold in the same way
i think the answer to that uh is no so
and again like in
a sense the project becomes special and
becomes essentially
decentralized it becomes realized in
satoshi's absence
and i think again that's why it's less
important who he is and his actions sort
of speak uh very loudly in that context
yeah and when you start to think about
kind of all of the body of work that you
were able to analyze what were the most
surprising things that maybe people
don't know about satoshi
or the things that you took away from
kind of this journey
yeah that's a great question i think the
most surprising thing was that people
just treated satoshi like a regular guy
i think they were very comfortable
complaining about him like wondering
where he was like doing very strange
things like tracking
like when he would appear on the forums
and like looking at his sleep schedule
right and i think there's some really
amusing anecdotes in the piece of
you know just people getting uh or even
object like outright objecting such
society's decisions right
we have this idea that like you know
maybe he was kind of uh benevolently
supported
in his time but yeah there are some
moments where satoshi makes decisions
that people aren't happy with
uh right there's um you know the bitcoin
users at one point you know the bitcoin
is a
successful project it's a million
dollars now all of a sudden
wikileaks this kind of big organization
that's doing a lot of work to undermine
uh you know release information about
governments the users want to support
them right they want
to show what unsensible money can do and
you know satoshi says no
i don't want to do this this is going to
quote kick the hornets nest right this
is going to send
the powers that be against us we don't
want to do that and then there's one
user who basically says
uh you know if if i can't send bitcoin
uh
you know this isn't bitcoin right he
goes on this kind of big street against
satoshi on the forums
that you can read right so i think um
like many leaders right people had a
complex relationship with satoshi i
think we we like to think that
you know satoshi's benevolent father
figure maybe like a
dorian nakamoto who we think of right
like this nice uh
you know sort of um again benevolent
paternal figure but i think for a lot of
people
at the time um you know it just became
such a big project for one person to
manage and i think that's really hit
home for me is that
you know satoshi in the beginning he is
the admin of the forum he he is the
admin of the website he's the person who
must update the code right him and a
very small group of people so
you know in this um you know as his time
gets more constrained as more users come
on board you really just kind of see
that he
falls to the pressure of you know almost
being unable to
satisfy all these users and i think to
me that's pretty amazing because if you
think about what it is that satoshi gave
us and what he achieved
um you know some of the complaints that
the users make against him
in retrospect like you know they might
be a little small like maybe he was a
few days late like making this update
that people wanted
and maybe they called him some names
that they shouldn't write but they
didn't know right it was they didn't
have this myth of satoshi right so we
have this idea today
of satoshi being this big mythological
character uh this legend uh you know we
can't know who he is
but in real time that wasn't the case
and that but that happened right and it
happened
in a very short time where he
disappeared and then he became a legend
and in a way it almost started happening
in his own time
as he became less accessible people
became more comfortable like
drawing pictures of him imagining what
he would look like if he was a woman
like all these sort of things where uh
they might seem sort of strange
if they didn't happen right because he
was a person who existed
and um you know people's relationship to
him changed over time and it was a
complicated relationship
so i noticed that you continue to use he
uh and most people when i talk to them
say he
she or they uh is that because you have
uh
conviction on it was a single individual
male
uh or is that just a a terminology that
you're using to simplify
uh conversation got it well actually so
one of the things that satoshi does to
evangelize for bitcoin because once he
puts it on the mailing list and he
releases the white paper he goes on this
website called the p2p foundation so you
know so she says okay well who can i get
involved in bitcoin like who's gonna
care about this crazy
decentralized money right so he goes to
this non-profit organization that again
has another online forum
and he registers an account so he makes
a user account on the p2p
foundation uh he says that he's a male
he gives his birth date
and he says that he's 46 years old and
then he
you know releases a bunch of comments
again we assume this is satoshi um
so i guess my claim would be that you
know when given the opportunity to be
identified
he she they it chose to be identified
as a man um and i guess in the spirit of
progressive values that seems to if
somebody wants to be
you know seen that way or test in that
way then i think we should honor that so
i think um
that would be my justification for it
but i think uh to me again one of these
details that we can't know
but uh again when given the opportunity
to identify that is how
he she it they identified yeah and uh
you mentioned
birthday uh kind of signifying like
mid-40s uh in terms of age
uh is there a thought in the back your
head of like oh this could be the real
birthday or this also could be
a birthday that's inputted to throw
people off the trail like how do you
just think through
some of the uh the information that
you're able to glean and and
the writing and things like this uh in
terms of what's
there as a clue if you will versus
what's almost left is like it something
to throw people off the trail
yeah i mean i i think satoshi leaves us
almost with nothing personal that's
that's what's really tough right it's a
you know i said at the beginning sort of
the opsec champion of the world um
right i think satoshi there's a reason
that he still is mysterious and one of
those reasons is that he doesn't
give a lot of personal information about
himself right we don't know if these
uh kind of facts and figures that he put
on the website the small things that he
did we don't we don't have any evidence
to know that if they're true
um and again even in the way that he
interacted with the internet
right he used primarily use this forum
that he created
there's no user data kind of associated
with that
and even in his interactions um you know
satoshi wasn't the type of person to
give small
talk if you had a question he would
answer and he would give his best
technical answer
but you know he's not on there talking
about his favorite baseball team or like
where he went to school or any of that
type of stuff right i think that there
are some instances where you can
and it's actually pretty surprising like
how few instances there are i think when
you
where you can derive that satoshi felt
something
through uh you know the series of his
actions because he is so reserved and i
think that
there's a remarkable sort of adjective
to give him he's very reserved
uh the piece goes into one of these
which i think is probably the most
formative satoshi event which is early
on
uh in in the bitcoin uh history of the
bitcoin network uh there is an attack on
the network right so
what happens over time is there's more
publicity for the project
uh the caliber of coders who are viewing
the code increases right and at some
point
you know they hit about a level you know
where satoshi is and essentially
people start reporting bugs to him and
in one case somebody decides to subvert
one of those bugs so in this case they
decided to
basically formulate their own piece of
software uh that
uh tricked bitcoin's accounting system
into just printing 180 billion bitcoins
onto the blockchain right so this is a
dramatic kind of event where the
monetary policy of bitcoin is broken
satoshi has to take the reins and
actually publish new code
convince all the users to switch to this
other blockchain and breaks the
blockchain for about
you know five hours from what we can
tell and in that instance
uh going forward so he becomes a lot
more reserved with his development right
he moves a lot faster
he starts to be less kind of open with
the contributors he's working with and
you know he starts really prioritizing
security making a lot of aggressive
changes to the software and exercising
his authority in ways where
you know probably if someone did that
today we wouldn't be able we wouldn't
say that that person maybe was acting in
the best interests of bitcoin
and really i don't even think someone
could act like that today right you'd
have to be in the position of satoshi so
i think
you know those things to me are the
interesting things that we can
um we can see right we that's that's the
kind of data we can get from looking at
these posts and looking
at them over time as we can see how he
reacted
how what those actions say right i think
from with the story anecdote that i
would just just told i think satoshi was
someone who put the security of bitcoin
on a very high pedestal right he was
willing to do things to protect
bitcoin um that you know again we can
look at and analyze
and we can we can draw conclusions about
his actions and i think that to me
uh sort of gets to the question when i'm
after which isn't really who
satoshi is but you know what bitcoin is
and how it operates
um and and what its you know values and
mechanics are
so talk to us about the disappearance
right kind of the end of satoshi's
um you know relationship with the
project or participation
uh at some point uh he decides to walk
away and so walk us just through maybe
sequentially kind of what happens there
at the end
yeah sure so uh you know the i would say
the last half of 2010 uh
is a really dramatic escalation in the
number of bitcoin users and
the the type of demands they have right
so i think early on
uh it's very i you know the concerns of
the users are very utilitarian they're
trying to use bitcoin
and they want to use it for things right
over the course of 2010
that really changes and it really
changes towards the end uh where there's
a series of discussions that i really
wanted to highlight
where all of a sudden you have these
like uh existential questions that are
being asked for the first time
right and it's amazing to me just how
like how quickly the succession of these
disagreements are
you know it starts off with should we
change the software to make it more
usable right something we still struggle
today
uh you know it's uh should the software
or the project be openly political right
should it align with wikileaks right
that's that's
still something i think you know
bitcoiners struggle with today
um you know there's also an incident
where satoshi uh you know decides that
uh he wants to turn off certain
transaction types where the users can't
you know do certain things on the
network anymore and people
you know sort of rebel against them they
say we want to we're going to run this
different code and we you know we don't
like this idea
right so i think there's a dramatic
escalation where uh the types of
disagreements
and like satoshi's ability to solve them
this is best personified by a thread
where
you know literally people are inventing
the idea of altcoins or other
cryptocurrencies or other blockchains
right there was just no
people had no conception of this there's
this thread that sort of lays out okay
well
hey there's this bitcoin thing what if
we designed another bitcoin to register
people's domain names and it was like an
application
where uh people could register domain
names and there was a bitcoin
type system and this just spirals into
these pages and pages and pages of
debate
about okay what our cryptocurrencies are
there more than one like should there be
more than one should we rebuild this
system
and is bitcoin the best version of this
should we actually start many versions
of these things
and there's no way for satoshi to answer
that right there's no way for any person
to answer that the market is still
is still figuring that out today but i
think towards the end there right there
is this sort of idea that
again the users have grown up there they
they have these demands that a satoshi
can't solve
and i think that as those things built
up he decided
you know basically it was time to walk
away that the users were essentially in
control
you can see his sign off and it's
observable in the code so one of the
neat things that i found
was that he actually relinquishes uh
well i don't know about relinquishes but
he he removes his name from the
copyright claim
and the software so he does sign off
there is an event where he takes his
name
out of that code base um and uh you know
he removes his name from the bitcoin art
website
right and he puts the names of other
developers and there's been a lot that
have been read into these different
events over the years people have
you know speculated about um how this
transition of power took place
whether satoshi picked a successor
whether his successor was a specific
individual
whether satoshi even had the power to
grant a successor at all because again
bitcoin is
is governed by users uh so the
transition i think uh
is a bit that that to me was really i
think a focal point where i wanted a
center on because i think in the
transition
you get a lot of interesting and uh you
know sort of questions right of what
does it mean to give up leadership of
bitcoin
what did it even mean to have leadership
of bitcoin to begin with
uh and i think uh that's that's sort of
why the disappearance is an interesting
moment
um in bitcoin's history uh because it is
so unique there just there just could
not have been another time
where the leader of the project
disappears and there wasn't
and um i just didn't think that really i
hadn't seen any real study of that
i've heard a lot of like you know uh
miss it like sort of you know stories
and tall tales about
uh you know certain developers going to
the cia
and certain other things happening right
and this also sort of gets washed around
and i think
you know what we can know is that the
environment around satoshi change
um we can speculate that that you know
his confidence in the community grew or
that he felt ready to walk away
uh and we we all we know is that he
signed off and that he
enabled another developer to take
control of the project
it's unclear what his relationship was
with that developer
um and again it's unclear whether this
authority was even satoshi's to give
right uh so i think again it remains
this interesting
slice in time where you get to look at a
decentralized monetary network
you know you think of a michael sailor
this is the the central bank of
cyberspace
this is going to be the digital goal
this is going to be the bedrock of the
financial system going forward
uh and here we have a small group of
people litigating the a very small
change of cryptographic keys
that actually controls the nuts and
bolts of the software
and someone has to hold those keys
someone has to be in charge someone has
to
do the work of continuing to manage the
code
so there's been a bunch of people who uh
speculate
on who they think satoshi is uh you
probably better than most have really
looked at a lot of the
the information uh some of the more
popular
uh answers to this type of question uh
is a nick zabo
uh hal finney um even at craig wright
there's a faction of people who believe
it's him um yeah you kind of go down the
line there's a whole bunch of different
people who
i think are again speculated to be
satoshi uh
are there any of those um you know kind
of story lines
or uh um you know ideas that seem
to fit the potential narrative or
rather than be so much focused on like
who is satoshi
are you able to at least disqualify
certain stories and say well it can't be
you know x y or z person because of the
work that you've done
right so it's almost like if you don't
try to figure out who it is can you get
closer by
saying no it's not people like the game
guess who or something you know
something like that yeah and and not so
much if you want to go through each
individual person we can do that or just
more so like
uh you know if you may even be able to
just say hey all of those
uh variations of the story don't make
sense to me for you know whatever reason
yeah look i mean i think speculation
about who satoshi is i you know again i
think
it's best left to cryptography right if
there is some individual and or group
that someday emerges that can move the
coins of satoshi or
you know in some way cryptographically
expressed that they are satoshi
i think other than that i don't think
there is a threshold right so one of the
interesting things is i sent this thread
around the time i published this article
which was essentially
you know no april 26 is the date of his
disappearance and if you believe in
cryptography
that has to be the date that is the date
that's that the figure
who was in control of the project we
assume is satoshi handed a cryptographic
key
to another developer and in that
expression of cryptography if
that is what we believe here that
cryptography is defining the rules of
the world then
that is the succession right that is the
point at which satoshi stopped
you know sort of being the manager of
the project and and i think in thinking
about that moment it was actually
amazing to me how little
we know about satoshi dal we actually uh
you know that
that simple act of him sending an empty
email with this key
it's probably one of the few messages
that we can actually prove ever came
from satoshi
because again um you know there is no
other than the you know kind of pgp
signature on the white paper
uh there's another never anything in the
forum posts a lot of his emails you know
have never really come out and there's
you know from what i've seen no kind of
identifying information on that
again this goes back to kind of the
opsec trail of just you know satoshi
being
in a lot of ways i think you can draw
his intent from this right he knew
eventually he would come under the
scrutiny
scrutiny and he put these steps in place
so
again i think speculation on who he is
if you believe in cryptography
uh then we don't have an answer
uh and we might never have an answer and
we may ultimately
be only left with a few moments to
really say definitively that this is
satoshi right i would say that
you know highly likely the individual
who was
attesting to be satoshi on the forums
who was actively making changes to the
code
was satoshi because everyone treated him
as satoshi right
so i mean um can we prove definitively
that it was satoshi
uh maybe not maybe it was a group of
people uh taking turns every day right
one guy
went on tuesdays and one guy went on
thursdays and uh there was
you know someone else who showed up on
weekends and pretend to be satoshi we
just simply
we simply don't know uh right i think um
satoshi was a person who wanted uh to
have
anonymity who i think knew again what
his project was going to do
he understood that right you can see
this from the first post that he makes
when he talks about
how this is going to break the model of
central banking
where this restores this to the people
who run the software
and i think you know yeah today the
people who run
the software are in control that's
that's what makes bitcoin so hard to
understand
that's why we keep wanting to ask these
questions about satoshi
and understanding and ultimately get
that answer because we want somebody to
look up to and we want an authority
figure
and i think it's amazing to the extent
that satoshi has denied us that
it says a lot about him what would
happen
what would happen if satoshi coins moved
right so those original coins that are
sitting there that have been dormant
uh you know literally since the uh the
beginning
uh if those moved would that be uh a big
deal would
it then become more important as to who
moved them uh just walk me through kind
of uh
that game if it was so to happen
yeah very interesting i mean obviously
from the market perspective i think
if you were to talk to an average
long-term
bitcoin holder or believer right they
would say that
uh it's highly unlikely that those coins
would ever moved and you could say that
the market has quote priced in
the idea that those coins will never
move right and we
we could say that i think the the modern
belief is that satoshi
in order to set the standard for the
project to set the principles of the
project
uh purposely never cashed in and has
ability to profit
and become wealthy from the project
right he never sold out or did any of
the other things that the leaders of the
other projects
have done and i think that remains a
really big differentiator for a lot of
people with bitcoin and other projects
because again
uh bitcoin did it wasn't uh a a
a form of value that came about through
uh market competition right people chose
to value bitcoin
they chose to use it none of the other
cryptocurrencies have have grown up
in that environment so i think with the
coins specifically
um yes there's a lot of uh i think
emotion and ideology attached to those i
think it would be
a moment in the project where a lot of
people would have to ask deep questions
about
what they think about the network so
again i think i can only speculate to
uh what the psychological reaction would
be because like again i think that that
kind of hits at what satoshi is to us to
this day right he
like it to an extent we are the ones who
um
you know give satoshi this power we we
um
you know associate these things with him
and i think um
you know again you're the you're the
investor right i think that uh i think
it would uh
cause some very interesting developments
in the market
um i would hope uh that you know as the
story kind of shows that
you know satoshi left at a time when
users were asserting that
um you know the project could survive
you know
even a a leader who would come back and
want to profit
and uh you know um subvert the project
or even attack it right because again
bitcoin today is controlled by users
uh we have the ability to elect the
software we want
influence that process uh provided we
can establish global consensus
and uh i think that you know i would
like to believe that that system can
survive that
uh because i would like to believe that
bitcoin was always more than just that
creator individual yeah i tend to agree
with you i think that uh
short term there would be uncertainty
potentially even chaos
you know price drop all kinds of uh just
frankly human
should not be good yeah just human
emotion driven things
uh long term though it feels to me like
even if satoshi came back
moved the coins uh and attacked the
project
right uh it's still um you know bitcoin
is at a point now where it's resilient
enough to survive something like that
um you know could be wrong but that's
kind of the the thought process over a
long period of time
short term though i think that you're
right and that just you know people are
really good at being fearful they're
very good at
um you know kind of succumbing to
uncertainty and so there would be a huge
issue uh in the short term probably a
pretty significant price drop
uh and then you know over time it kind
of all all nets out so it's
it's fascinating to think about what uh
what are the questions
that you still have after kind of going
through this whole process where you're
like ah you know
there's one or two things that i wish i
knew the answers to but i don't
um yeah that's interesting question i
would say one of the things that i'm
still trying to figure out is to what
extent did satoshi complete bitcoin and
then if he didn't complete bitcoin
who did right and really how to answer
this question because i
think and i and i describe this as like
kind of a thought paradox
um you know pretty recently where you
imagine you're the person who
invented decentralized money that's
pretty
weird right like you would acknowledge
that the point that bitcoin was invented
that satoshi invented bitcoin
that bitcoin did not meet the definition
of bitcoin right because in order to be
bitcoin
uh the money bitcoin money had to be
decentralized the system had to be free
uh from control and the system had to
have a series of features
uh that was meaningfully differentiated
from the prior fiat currency so i think
it's interesting to think about okay
well did satoshi actually ever
complete bitcoin and if so when did he
complete it when was the point bitcoin
was the centralized when it was
when there was two people is that your
answer like was bitcoin complete at that
stage
and then if not well okay like well then
when was bitcoin completed
i think as i began to think about that
i've i've i do think that there was a
larger
uncredited group of people who did help
complete bitcoin i do not think that
satoshi's singuli
can be credited as the sole inventor of
bitcoin because bitcoin had to move
beyond him
bitcoin could not have been meaningfully
decentralized while he was still in
control
and therefore i think you can look at
the bitcoin that satoshi left as being
unfinished
so then i think the question for me gets
to well who are the people who carry
this through
who are the ones who understand what
satoshi was trying to build and then
what did they specifically add
uh to the pie here to complete that
whether it was on in the technology
or the philosophy i think we can look
back over you know 12 years now
and even amongst crypto currencies
bitcoin is a highly unique project it
has made
very specific decisions that stand in
contrast to almost every other
project almost every other
cryptocurrency project is led by a group
of developers
who believe today that if they want to
fork that system
and make your money operate under
different conditions
then they can do that that is literally
the rules of most cryptocurrencies
uh and they believe that the free market
of choice of the among those
cryptocurrencies is enough
to justify that i think bitcoin has a
very different philosophy today
uh it is based on the idea that bitcoin
is an alternative to the fiat currency
system that you as an individual
within that system should be no greater
or less than any other user that your
rights and guarantees to that value
should be equal among your peers right
so i think that
um for me i want to understand where
that comes from because to me that is
bitcoin that's where bitcoin's gotten to
and that's and maybe that's what it
always was uh but again i traced this
back to the sort of an
initial contradiction where was it
possible for satoshi to really
understand bitcoin
was it possibly for him possible for him
to have completed it
or was the thing that he created a rough
half-finished quarter finished project
that
needed a set of individuals to take it
forward right you can go back to
satoshi's writings and you can see the
contradictions you can you
get you know bits and pieces where even
his response to the idea that there
should be multiple cryptocurrencies
right he invents this concept called
merge mining which is the idea that
multiple cryptocurrencies can share
hashing power which today amongst
developers is kind of an outmoded idea
right and you could say okay that was a
10 years old satoshi idea
um but you know again i think that um
we can look at the contradictions of him
and see that uh
it wasn't possible for him to have every
answer
right that what he created did become
bigger than himself
uh and that's why i prefer to look at it
as you know bitcoin is
you know uh i would say now a more
completed project maybe it's maybe it
has more left to grow
and that satoshi is a meaningful
contributor to that
but that there are others and i think as
i look for
where my work is going to continue i
really want to find who those specific
people
are who are the people who contributed
something meaningful to the bitcoin
ideology
uh because i think uh to me those are
the beautiful kind of moments of bitcoin
and again this comes from the vision of
uh if this is a human invention if this
you know in
a thousand years we'll look back and
it's you know the rotary phone the
internet and bitcoin are the
you know the staggering achievements i
think uh it's fascinating to me to think
that there are individuals who
contributed to that and i and i want to
understand who those
who those people were it's absolutely
fascinating to me especially given the
fact that uh we will likely never have
the answers
uh to a lot of these questions but uh
but it is
uh it's incredibly important bitcoin has
grown to a trillion dollar asset without
the answers
uh and i don't think that we necessarily
need the answers it's more so just
you i and everyone else uh being you
know intellectually intrigued by uh by
some of this
uh before i let you go ask everyone the
same three questions you'll get to ask
me one to finish
up uh first is just what's the most
important book you've ever read
uh to me personally or yeah or just to
okay
huh that's one that i haven't thought of
in a while um
and this is this can just be any book
any sort of whatever is the most
important for you
yeah i mean i'm a literary person i like
books i like reading for writing i guess
i would say my favorite book was
treasure
island as a kid so maybe that's probably
the most important to me since i became
a writer
and i think um i'd like to think you
know it was that sense of adventure of
writing right so for me personally
writing is about
trying to get across uh again adventure
or excitement to people right so
when i write these stories uh like last
days of satoshi it's
i hope that my excitement for that
narrative can kind of push people to
understanding some of these complexities
of the bitcoin subject matter they might
not otherwise engage with so i think
uh maybe that's a bit more like me
personally as a as a
writer or person i think that's where i
woke up to the idea of writing
and why writing has stayed with me uh
and i think i said that would be the
most important book for me
that's a great answer uh second question
comes from our friends that ate sleep
uh i sleep five or six hours now i sleep
like eight or nine
i use their thermoregulated bed so i
just make it really really cold
uh it helps me sleep better what's your
sleep schedule and how's that changed
over the last two or three years
uh interesting i'm pretty rock solid i'm
a regular i gotta get in there at 9 30
and i get up at like six in the morning
i think uh i'm uh i'm a finely tuned
clock
uh once once once you set it uh you know
i'm i don't wake up i don't need an
alarm
uh it's gonna be the same time every day
uh for me um
they say that's one of the most
important things is uh going to sleep at
the same time
yep yeah so i think for me i mean i'm
just i'm i'm a person of habits uh
and uh you know maybe stay up an hour or
two later on on the weekends but
uh mostly not uh mostly not deviating
from that schedule
i love it uh last question aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
uh definitely a believer yeah it's
really pessimistic to think that we're
the only people in this
uh really ever expanding increasingly
complex and silly universe
i i honestly think that would be
horrifying i think i think that we
uh yeah i think we have to want aliens
to exist right because otherwise how do
we know we're not like some
hilarious tragic mistake right i think
like i think aliens
if we find aliens uh there's someone
else there right like there's some
there's some brotherhood or kinship so
like even if they were to try to
you know exterminate us i mean i think
it would still be nice like to know
uh that you know there's something else
going on here
because i think you know we still exist
in this you know the historical lens
right we still exist in this time where
we're alone in the universe right i i
think like it will
i do buy that it will be a watershed
moment if that changes uh
but again i think it's like uh you think
about the opposite like if we're just
the only things i think you have to
start kind of going down the rabbit hole
of like oh was
is consciousness like an evolutionary
mistake or like some of those things
that
uh i don't know for me are a little bit
dark right i uh
i try not to go down those paths but uh
i'm for aliens if only for like the
intellectual comfort that they will
provide us i love it
uh you could ask me one question to
finish off what you got for me
interesting um
super cycle you i think as a person
who's understanding
the psychology of people probably
better than most um do you believe that
uh bitcoin is as
heading towards a watershed moment of
adoption
uh and if so
why do you think that psychologically uh
where
the world at large is is ready for that
moment
i don't have the answers i can't predict
the future i i think the way that i
would
think through this frankly is uh there's
actually a disconnect in my opinion
between price
and uh like mainstream adoption right so
one of the things you have to remember
is the people who are mostly coming into
the market
at least from an aggregate dollar
standpoint are institutions
so you can have you know a million
people sign up and all want to spend 500
bucks but if you just have a you know
two or three
uh various institutions show up they're
gonna have more money
right and so like actually from like a
capital inflow standpoint
the institutions are gonna be much more
uh heavily correlated to price
than like the mainstream adoption of
retail users uh so i think it's
important to kind of separate those two
things out
uh in terms of the retail user
i do however think that as the us dollar
value of the asset goes up
uh people feel like they have gotten
quote-unquote richer
and therefore they then are more likely
to actually spend
that asset right and so you get more of
kind of the commerce
uh element that's attached to it and
ultimately you know you have eventually
not in the short term but over the long
period of time
you'll likely get some level of
stability
uh in the currency and when you get that
then uh
there's a complete you know use of the
currency there's no more belief that hey
by holding this
today uh it will be worth more in the
future right it's kind of uh
you've reached that price stability uh
and so i think from a super cycle
standpoint i think a lot of
folks are uh so focused on like retail
adoption and psychology i so more look
at it from an institutional standpoint
and
i think that one of the key questions uh
is are there retail
or i'm sorry are the institutions a
blessing or a curse so i'll walk you
through two scenarios one is
institutions come in they buy a bunch of
bitcoin there's really not that much
bitcoin for sale 60
hasn't moved in the last 12 months more
and more are coming off exchanges every
day
and so really there's only about five to
seven million bitcoin that are changing
hands you know in any kind of given
period
uh institutions show up they buy that
institutions have strong hands they
don't sell they don't care about
volatility and therefore
uh we are less likely to get uh kind of
an 85
drawdown you know as we end this uh
bull market that's kind of one argument
the other argument
is that the institutions actually have
the weakest hands and the second that it
draws down 20 30 40 percent they just
offload everything and they're like you
know screw this thing
uh and they actually perpetuate like a
faster uh
drawdown and so 85 ends up being
conservative and like maybe it actually
is like
95 i don't know what plays out uh i'm
frankly
not so much focused on that at the
moment i think that we've still got
quite a bit
uh left in this bull market you know
we're recording this in uh in
early may of 2021 uh and so let's see
what happens kind of over the next
couple of months but i do
think that um there's a an inverse
relationship
uh between how high you go uh and
uh kind of what the the drawdown is
right in terms of the higher you go
uh just the further the drawdown uh
historically
would have been right so uh if in 2017
bitcoin had gone to 10
and then drew down uh obviously that is
uh
less of a drawdown than if it goes to 20
and it draws all the way down to 3 200
and so i think similar here is uh the
more that the
bull market is uh kind of bullish with a
violent move upwards
uh just the potential more pain on the
other side now to the true bitcoiners
uh i don't think that that necessarily
shakes their confidence
right uh i think frankly it actually may
uh almost be an expectation of theirs
um and so you know again that's kind of
what makes it fun right if
if the whole thing was just hey acquire
as much bitcoin as possible and just
hold it and
we didn't have any of this stuff to talk
about like who is satoshi or
um you know anything around kind of
market cycles and stuff
i think we would all get bored just
sitting on our hands you know kind of
living our lives yeah i think that was
also a little bit of a question about
market psychology and just
to me i think one of the things that's
still kind of uh maybe a little bit
disheartening is just how little the
media narrative has
shifted you know you still see the
attention on on dogecoin and those type
of events so i think
uh also was interesting to get your
pulse on uh just you know
whether there has been any uh you know
whether we're really as a movement
you know kind of kind of pushing forward
there and making headway
so i actually think we're gonna go the
opposite direction which may or may not
be a good thing
but uh and this is more of a macro
tailwind
of just the gamification of finance in
general right this isn't a bitcoin thing
it's not a crypto thing
it's just everything right and
ultimately what's happening is
when you bring down the barriers to
financial markets
one you increase access which most
people i think i think is a good thing
two is you increase the ability for
wealth generation which i think most
people think is a good thing
but three is also you're going to get
much more speculation in markets you're
going to get a lot more gamification
around it you're going to get a lot more
entertainment factor out of it than when
it's only just quote unquote the
professionals
right uh and so i think that we just
have to understand
uh when you reduce the barriers or you
reduce that friction
this is a natural side effect and in
some way it's actually a signal that
uh the friction is being reduced right
there is more access now
and so i think you know one of the the
funniest things that's happened in the
last i don't know 6 12 months
is uh everyone's yelling and screaming
at robin hood and so their solution to
being yelled at was
we're gonna remove the confetti after
you've made a trade
right now here's the problem right and
you know not to discount they did a lot
of different things but that was one of
the
kind of paths that they chose to pursue
but the confetti falls
after you've purchased the security
right it's not a thing where hey if we
remove this then people are less likely
to buy it
it's kind of a dopamine hit after you've
already taken the action
and so i don't know if there's
necessarily users who are like going on
robin hood trying to
buy a stock just to get the confetti to
fall on their screen
right and so i think that like that's
the type of stuff where
uh are we really solving the the problem
people are talking about or are we doing
more things that like almost make us
feel like there's uh
uh activity but not yet progress right i
think that's kind of what you're talking
about here is
uh there's a lot of activity people are
talking about it
but if you really want to address the
problem then
to me the number one way to address the
problem and actually get true progress
is through financial education right
like if you don't want people
speculating in markets and thinking that
they're gambling
then go teach them how to invest because
if you teach them how to invest you can
take away the
mentality of like odds right and that
like gambling dopamine hit type
uh approach and you can actually show
them how to get rich
and i always go back to this quote that
my father used to tell me all the time
he said listen
there's nothing more fun than winning
right and so
sure there's some people who enjoy
gambling but there's way more
people who enjoy getting rich right and
building wealth and so i think that
really all
boils down to that financial education
and then what you'll get is the more
educated market you have the more
sophisticated market you have
you go back to less of the speculation
more um you know kind of professionalism
of a market from a market structure
standpoint
and the likely thing there is you
actually get much less volatility
um and kind of all these other you know
benefits of of that financial education
yeah i think i was asking that also just
because bringing back to satoshi it's
you know i think i get a lot more
these days of an understanding of
appreciation of just like what a
meaningful critique like bitcoin was
of the system like we think about like
the way that we were living our lives
prior to bitcoin and the way that the
systems were designed like what a like
like what a thing to leave behind right
if you were you're the person like
the act of inventing bitcoin uh you know
it cuts the heart of like consumerism
uh capitalism like the way that uh
markets function
uh the way that national economies
function uh
really just kind of remarkable i think
in just terms of like imagine being that
person
who really saw through all of that right
it's taken me so long to like understand
bitcoin right it took me like i've been
in this industry
you know going on nine years it took me
that long to understand it and just to
be
the person who put that together uh i
just you know i keep going back to it
it's like man what a
what a deeply meaningful critique on
like human existence and if you're gonna
sign off from the world
uh you know having done bitcoin godspeed
i could not agree more my friend so
listen thank you so much for doing this
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or to uh to read your work
on satoshi
yeah at twitter at pete's underscore
rizzo underscore
uh the articles the last days of satoshi
what happened when bitcoin's creator
disappeared
that's out on bitcoin magazine you can
catch a summary of that on forbes.com as
well
uh and again yeah editor over at bitcoin
magazine now uh
also editor at large over at kraken and
as mentioned uh you know
overseeing their open source developer
grants of your developer working on a
great project
you know you need to help need some
support uh feel free to get in touch
always looking to work with uh great
people who are moving at the industry
and moving forward so
awesome man listen thank you so much
pete as always it's a pleasure talking
and watch do it again in the future
cool man appreciate it